The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So good afternoon.
Let's have an on-time departure.
Last week, we talked about
quantum states of light.
So we're talking about the
photon, the quantum description
of the electromagnetic field.
And I introduced for you the
most classical quantum state
of the electromagnetic field,
namely the coherent state.
I don't want to go through
the formalism again,
but the coherent state
has a simple definition,
simple but subtle.
It's an eigenstate of the
annihilation operator,
and it has a complex
eigenvalue alpha.
And from that, you
can pretty much
derive everything you want to
know about coherent states.
Colin.
AUDIENCE: What was the
purpose of-- whoever
discovered eigenstates-- what
was the purpose of trying
to find the eigenvalues
of destruction?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
isn't that subtle?
Isn't that weird?
How does somebody want to
find the eigenfunctions
of an annihilation operator,
because the annihilation
operator is non-Hermitian?
And why the
annihilation operator?
Why not the creation operator?
Well, if you try to find the
eigenstates of the creation
operator, you run into problems.
The eigenstates are
non-normalizable.
It doesn't make any sense.
So here, creation and
annihilation are not symmetric.
You have to pick the
annihilation operator.
Colin, my gut feeling is
that somebody found it
in a different way.
The person who popularized
those states was [INAUDIBLE],
and he got amply
rewarded for that.
And I think you
define coherent state
as some form of
superposition state.
Maybe people have figured out
if you take a superposition
state of number states that
this has special properties,
that this is a minimum
uncertainty state, which
is as close as we can
go in quantum physics
to obtain a classical
electric field.
So I think maybe people
found it like that.
And then they say, hey, but
there is another operator
definition eigenstate of
the annihilation operator.
I'm 99 percent certain.
But maybe you can
ask [INAUDIBLE]
when he comes to a CUA seminar
if he discovered coherent state
as eigenstates of the
annihilation operator.
I don't think so.
Other questions?
So what I want to do
is-- what the theme
of the end of last
lecture and today
is that the coherent
state is a complex number.
The coherent state
has a time evolution.
It moves in a circle.
And this is really the phasor
of the electric field associated
with it.
So coherent state,
the alpha value
is directly related
to an electric field.
That's why this state
is closely related
to the classical limit of
the electromagnetic field.
We discussed some properties
of the coherent state.
We looked at the
fluctuations and showed
that it's a
Poissonian statistic.
And then we use now--
once you define something,
you can use it as a tool.
We are now using
the coherent states
to look at any
other quantum state
of the electromagnetic field,
any statistical operator which
describes photons by
forming the diagram matrix
element of the statistical
operator with alpha.
If you just want to sort of
think about it intuitively,
alpha is like the
best description
of an electromagnetic field.
So if you write
down this, we ask,
What is the probability for
an arbitrary quantum state
described by an arbitrary
statistical operator-- what
is the probability that
the electric field is
alpha in the
complex description?
So that's what those
quasi-probabilities
are-- Q of alpha.
And we immediately looked
at some examples, of course,
of probabilities.
We showed that the vacuum
state is sort of an area.
It's a Gaussian.
And the area is-- it's an area.
I don't know.
I forgot the [? prefect. ?]
It's on the order of 1 or 1/2.
We realize that
thermal states are also
a Gaussian centered
at the origin.
But it is a much
wider distribution.
So thermal states have
much more uncertainty
in the electric field
than the vacuum state.
And then we looked at
the coherent state.
And now, of course, when we
looked at the coherent state,
we realize that coherent
states are maybe not
as wonderful as I tried
to make you believe.
They have some nasty properties.
And that is when you ask,
What is the probability?
The quasi-probability of the
coherent state would be beta.
Now, if you would
expect a delta function,
because when you ask, What is
the probability of a momentum
state to be p naught?
If you have a momentum
state p naught,
it has a delta
function at p naught.
But here, it's not
a delta function.
It's a Gaussian of the
standard deviation.
I think the standard deviation
here is-- what is it,
square root 1 over
square root 2?
Because the Gaussian has
usually 2 times sigma squared.
And since the
denominator is unity--
so the standard deviation
of 1 over square root 2.
And that showed us that
the coherent states are not
orthogonal.
You have to be a
little bit careful.
It's not your
standard basis set.
It's an overcomplete basis.
So therefore the
coherent state is not
a delta function in
the causal probability.
It's a little bit blurred
circle with an area
on the order of unity.
And you have some homework
assignment to look at it.
So in some way, how
you should look at
it is that if you see some
quasi-probability distribution,
the distance from
the origin-- this
is the absolute value
of the electric field.
The phase here is
almost 45 degrees.
But if you look at
this uncertainty,
you would also say,
Well, the phase
is uncertain to
within this angle.
So you can pretty much
read the uncertainty
in the total electric field,
the uncertainty in the phase.
You can read pretty
much everything
you want from this diagram.
Now, when we look at
a number state-- Well,
you often know in
quantum mechanics,
number and phase
are complimentary.
If the number of
photons is fixed,
you know nothing
about the phase.
And indeed the quasi-probability
of a number state is a ring.
It has no phase.
It has completely random
phase over the 2 pi circle.
The energy is sharp
of a number state,
since the energy is e squared.
You may have expected
a delta function
in the radial coordinate.
But what you get
is also something
blurred on the order of unity.
And I want to say something
about that in a second.
Finally, we discuss
the time dependence.
And the time dependence
is very easy.
After all, we're dealing
with an harmonic oscillator.
And in an harmonic
oscillator, if you
have a plane of x and p,
symmetric and anti-symmetric
combination of a and a
dagger, in this plane
in an harmonic oscillator,
the quantum state
is just rotating circle,
a rotation with omega.
And indeed we showed that when
we apply the time evolution
operator-- and some of
you were right, of course,
with a minus sign-- it moves
with e to the minus i omega t.
And therefore everything
rotates in a clockwise way.
Now, we discussed the operator
of the electric field.
And in this
quasi-probability-- Sorry,
we discussed the operator
of the electric field.
And I hope you remember
that in the analogy
with the harmonic oscillator,
the electric field was
a minus a dagger.
And this is the
momentum operator.
In those quasi-probabilities--
and we will see more about it--
something which is
sharp in momentum
is a sliver parallel
to the x-axis.
So therefore, you can
regard the vertical axis,
which is the imaginary part of
alpha, as the momentum axis.
And you can regard this
as-- the horizontal axis--
as the x-axis.
So therefore, since
momentum is electric field,
you always get
the electric field
by projecting onto
the vertical axis.
And if you project
this fuzzy ball,
you get a value 0
with some uncertainty.
And if this
quasi-probability starts
to rotate due to
the time evolution,
we get an oscillating
electromagnetic field, almost
classical except
for that fuzziness.
So that's where we
want to continue.
Any questions about that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why is there no
phase fuzziness in the E t?
PROFESSOR: No phase fuzziness.
There is a phrase fuzziness.
For instance, if you would
say the phase is determined
by the 0 crossing, you don't
know exactly when the 0
crossing happened,
and that corresponds
to an uncertainty in the phase.
Trust me, everything
is in this diagram.
Now, there are two things
we want to continue.
One is I want to show you
that the coherent state is
a minimum uncertainty state.
The product of delta
x delta p is just--
is it h-bar or h-bar over two?
One of the two.
So it's a minimum
uncertainty state.
And therefore, you can
never have a quantum state
which is less fuzzy
than the coherent state.
So this fuzziness here is
the intrinsic uncertainty
of quantum physics.
So that's what we
want to discuss today.
But then we will
immediately start
with non-classical states.
And that is, well, if
this area is determined
by Heisenberg's
uncertainty relation, what
can be maybe deform the
circle into an ellipse,
and these are three
states of light.
So that's an outlook.
That's what you're going
to do in the second half
of the class.
But before I do that, I
want to be a little bit more
accurate about
quasi-probabilities.
And this is almost
like a disclaimer now.
Just to give you
the bigger picture.
What we want to achieve with
those quasi-probabilities,
we want to do what phase space
densities in classical physics.
We have a coordinate which is
x, a coordinate which is p.
And you can often describe
a classical system
if you know the phase
space distribution,
if you know the probability
that a particle has
position x and momentum p.
So all this is about
phase space densities.
Probability of x and p.
Of course, writing it down, you
immediately see the problem.
In quantum mechanics, you cannot
measure x and p simultaneously.
These are non-commuting
variables.
So therefore, what happens is,
if you now define a phase space
function, which is done in
quantum mechanics textbooks,
you can actually do it
in three different ways.
And the three different
ways are Q, P, and W.
The definition--
I don't want to go
through the mathematical
subtleties-- the definition
of those functions involves
the operator definition, a
and a dagger, or,
which is equivalent,
the x and p operator.
If you define something in units
of x and p or a and a dagger,
you can have a product
which is fully symmetric i
in the ordering of x p, which
is anti-normal or normal.
So in other words,
the order matters.
And you have three choices.
In an operator product, you can
have symmetric ordering, which
means not x p, but x p
plus p x, then it's over 2.
That's symmetric.
You can have an ordering
which is called normal
and one which is
called anti-normal.
Ordering of operators in the
operator base definition.
Of course, if you
have three choices,
you would say, Which
one is the best?
Which one is the winner?
But the fact is all three
have their advantages
and disadvantages.
So they all have
pluses and minuses.
The reason why I picked
for the course Q of alpha
is that it's a real probability,
it's always positive.
It is a diagonal matrix element
of a statistical operator,
and this has to be positive.
So it's a real probability.
The other guys, P of alpha,
can be positive or negative.
And also, W of alpha can
be positive or negative.
So if you use a P
alpha distribution
statistical operator, it
can be written like this.
And as a result, the coherent
state is now not this Gaussian.
It doesn't have this
Gaussian distribution
as a course of probability.
It's what you want--
what maybe some of you
wanted to see-- oh, by the
way, it's a delta function.
The probability of the
coherent state alpha
has a delta function peak at
alpha, which is sort of nice.
And the number state is not
a ring of a finite radius.
I just mentioned to
you the number state.
You would naively expect
the energy is sharp.
The square root of the
energy's electric field,
shouldn't it be sharp?
And indeed, it is sharp.
It's actually worse
than a delta function.
It's a derivative
of a delta function.
But at least here,
in the probability P,
which is also called
the Glauber-Sudarshan P
representation, you
get the delta function,
which may be very natural
for certain purposes.
AUDIENCE: Since the [INAUDIBLE]
and you can express one
in terms of the
other, is that unique?
PROFESSOR: It is unique by
some symmetry choice here.
So that's the advantage
of it, that by-- I'm not
going into the mathematics.
I'm not giving
you the definition
but the way how it's defined.
It's unique.
It can be written in such a way.
And the way how the
quasi-probabilities
P-- the P representation--
is defined,
you get a delta function
at the coherent state.
And finally, W stands
for Wigner distribution.
And the Wigner distribution
is something you actually
find in most quantum
mechanics textbooks.
The Q and P distribution are
more common in quantum optics.
But the Wigner distribution
has the advantage
that the projection
on the x- and y-axes
are indeed psi of x
squared, psi of p squared.
So you get actually the x
wave function and the p wave
function.
So now, as a full
disclaimer, if you
want the electric field, which
is the momentum of the harmonic
oscillator, which is the
electromagnetic field, what you
really want to project is the
W function, because for the W
function, the Wigner
function, the projection
is exactly the
momentum distribution
in the electric field.
So the Wigner distribution is
closest to the classic phase
space distribution,
as close as you
come without
violating commutators.
But of course it
has a disadvantage
that it has negative values.
And try to explain to
your next neighbor what
is a negative probability.
Some people actually see
negative probabilities spring
out the non-classical character.
And I know in our
field, in AMO physics,
a few years ago, in
my lifetime, there
were really attempts to use
quantum state homography
and measure for the first time
a negative Wigner distribution
and show that to the world.
So that meant something
to a lot of people.
Anyway, you can read about it
in quantum physics textbooks.
All I want you to know
is to know about it,
but then also just relax.
In the bigger picture, all
the three distributions
are the same.
It's more sort of on the
level of whether something
is a delta function
or has widths unity.
So on the small
scale, it matters.
But if you map out
something on a bigger scale,
they are all related
to each other.
And for the rest off
today and the next class,
when I show you those phase
space distribution, when
I say I project onto
the vertical axis
to get the electric
field, I'm not
completely rigorous which
of the three functions
I've really chosen.
Any questions?
OK.
So I promised you--
and this is what
we're going to do now is
we're want to understand
in more depth the fluctuations.
And in particular,
I want to show you
that coherent states are
minimum uncertainty states.
So by identifying the
vertical axis with p,
the horizontal axis with
x, we immediately expect
that we find a result related
the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle, which says sit the
widths in P and the widths in Q
has to be larger
than h-bar over 2.
And we are mainly talking with
light about the photon creation
and annihilation operator.
But, just as a reminder, the
momentum and position operator
are symmetric and
anti-symmetric combinations.
So let me just call
those [? prefecters ?]
Q naught and this one P naught.
Well, we can then
immediately, by just
using elementary
commutator, calculate
what are the expectation values
in a coherent state for P,
P squared, Q, and Q squared.
For P, it is-- the P
operator is a dagger minus a.
If we act with a on
alpha, we get alpha,
because alpha-- the
coherent state--
is an eigenstate of alpha.
Now, with a dagger we act
on the left hand side.
And we get alpha star.
Well, with P squared
and Q squared,
you have to use one
or two more steps
to get rid of the products.
But ultimately, you can
express space all that just
in powers of alpha, alpha
squared, alpha star, and such.
So what we want is
we want to find out
what are the fluctuations delta
Q, delta P. Just as a reminder,
delta Q squared is of course Q
squared average minus Q average
squared.
And Q squared
average and Q squared
is what we have just calculated.
Actually, let me leave it
in as a reminder for you--
Q squared minus Q average
squared, the square root of it.
And what we find is that it's
square root h-bar over 2 omega
and, for delta P, it is square
root h-bar over omega 2.
And what we verify, that
indeed, for a coherent state,
the product of the 2 is
Heisenberg uncertainty limit.
So therefore, coherent states
are minimum uncertainty states.
And maybe, Colin, to
address your question,
I could imagine that
coherent states were maybe
invented by simply saying, We
have an harmonic oscillator
data.
We want to find the
minimum uncertainty
states for which the
uncertainty in x and p,
when expressed in natural
units, is the same.
In other words,
the coherent state
is the solution to the
following question.
If you plot the
quasi-probability distribution,
you give yourself
an uncertainty area.
One horizontal
uncertainty is delta Q.
The vertical
uncertainty is delta P.
And the minimum
uncertainty state
means that the area of the
2 uncertainties, the area
of the shaded region, delta P
times delta Q is h-bar over 2.
Or if I want to
rewrite that in-- Yes,
in the real part of alpha
times the uncertainty
in the imaginary part of alpha
for the quasi-probability,
then this is 1/4.
OK.
So what we have learned
is that-- just one second.
We have learned about one way
to characterize uncertainties--
the quantumness of the
electromagnetic field--
by looking at the uncertainties
in the x and p variable.
And that led us to minimum
uncertainty states.
Now, I want to now
introduce to you
two other ways of characterizing
the uncertainty of quantum
states of light.
One is we can ask, What are
the fluctuations in the photon
number?
Right now, we have
asked, What are
the fluctuations in
the electric field?
But the next
question is, What are
the fluctuations in
the photon number?
Or we can ask, what
are fluctuations
in the intensity when
we measure the intensity
of the electromagnetic field?
So let's do that.
The fluctuations-- It
seems I've lost my lines.
OK.
So the fluctuations
of the intensity
are usually expressed by the
second order temporal coherence
function.
That's what we want
to introduce now.
Yes, this is the second
order temporal correlation
or coherence function.
What I'm always
encountering in this course
is I would just like
to immediately tell you
how it is defined in terms
of a's and a daggers.
It's simple.
It's quantum mechanical.
It's exact.
But I always feel that if
you want to really appreciate
the quantum character, you have
to know the classic description
first.
So I want to first tell you what
is the second order coherence
function for
classical light, which
has a classic description.
And then you'll see
what is the difference
for quantum states of light.
So the classical
description is you
measure the intensity of light.
You're just sitting here.
You receive light
from a light bulb.
You measure the
intensity at time t.
You measure the intensity
at time tau later.
And then you form the product.
And you normalize it by the
average intensity squared.
So if tau equals 0,
it's nothing else
than the intensity
squared average divided
by the average of the
intensity squared.
So this is the classical
definition, g2 of tau.
And I've left the
proof to the homework
to show that the classical g2
of tau is always larger than 1.
But it's pretty much what
you show is for tau equal 0,
it means I squared
average is larger
than I average squared, which
is, of course, always the case.
But you can show that this is
also the case for finite tau.
So quantum mechanically, we will
see that the g2 function is not
necessarily larger than 1,
it can be smaller than 1.
And that's actually
an interesting--
you can see-- litmus
test for the quantumness.
If you generate states of the
electromagnetic field-- Fock
states, photon number states--
we see that in a moment.
And they have a g2 of tau
which is smaller than 1.
You know it is not
possible in any way
to associate an intensity
of the electromagnetic field
with that photon
state, because whenever
you can associate a
classical intensity with it
and use a classical intensity
to calculate the second order
correlation function,
you get something
which is larger than 1.
So often therefore
again, when people
want to show we really have now
non-classical photon states,
they show g2 of tau
is smaller than 1.
This is similar to
what I said before when
you want to show that you
have non-classical light,
you do quantum state
homography, measure the Wigner
distribution, and show that
the Wigner distribution has
negative quasi-probabilities.
That's again something which
is classically not possible.
It's only possible if you have
a truly non-classical state.
AUDIENCE: So in the
definition of g2 classical,
the expectation values would
need averaging over time, not
over ensembles of I of t?
PROFESSOR: OK.
You can average over ensembles.
So you can have 1,000 light
bulbs, switch them all on,
and then measure at
a certain time z.
But what we assume here
is that the light bulb
is on continuously.
So things don't
really depend on t.
I've implicitly taken care of
it by defining the g2 function
only of tau and
not of t and tau.
You assume any time is the same,
because it's a distribution,
it's this ensemble
in steady state.
But it's sort of the same
story again and again.
In classical physics, you can
determine an ensemble average
by taking an ergotic
system and observing it
at many, many times.
And then the idea is
that one system as time
goes by will sample
all possible states.
Or you can prepare many,
many identical systems
and do more of what is
an ensemble average.
So in other words,
you would actually
think, if you switch on a
light bulb with a stable power
supply, that the light
emitted by the light bulb
will go through all possible
quantum states as time evolves.
And therefore, the
temporal average
is equal to the
ensemble average.
So how do we generalize
that to quantum mechanics?
Well, one possibility
would be that-- OK.
First of all, for
quantum mechanics,
we have to use operators.
And one choice would
be that, well, you
say the intensity of
the electromagnetic wave
is proportional to the
electric field squared.
And you want to use the operator
for the electric field squared.
Now, there is a little
bit of a problem,
because what we really
mean quantum mechanically
by g2 of tau is we
measure the intensity now
and a little bit later.
But measuring the intensity
really means absorbing photons,
because the only way how you can
measure the intensity of light
is with a photomultiplier.
It makes click, the
photon is absorbed.
And this is not fully described
by the electric field.
Just assume you
have no photon, you
are in the zero-point state
of your harmonic oscillator,
and your E squared has
zero-point fluctuations.
So what is more closely
related to an experiment how
you measure the
correlation function is
you want to look
at something else,
namely at the probability
of absorbing 2 photons.
So you start with
an initial state.
You annihilate 2 photons.
And then you have a final state.
But if you're only
interested in what
is the probability you
want to characterize
your initial state, you may want
to sum over all final state.
And this is your
total probability
that you can absorb 2 photons
out of an initial state.
But since you're in sum
now over all final state,
this turns into--
Now, I could put
for you as in the final
state is a complete basis.
But I can also take it out.
So this is what we get.
So this suggests
that experiments
where we look at two subsequent
clicks of a photomultiplier
where we determine the
photon correlation,
that this is measuring a
correlation function, which,
for quantum states of
light, should be defined
as the expectation value of
a dagger, a dagger, a, a.
And now we have to normalize
by the probability squared
of absorbing 1 photon, which
is a dagger a expectation
value squared.
I just tried to be a
little bit too motivated.
In many, many textbooks,
the discussion
would start with
this expression.
You ask, Where
does it come from?
And you realize yes,
for some measurement
with photomultipliers,
that's what you measure.
But I wanted to show you how
it is related to the intensity
correlation function
defined classically.
Cody.
AUDIENCE: But this
looks like it's
constant in tau,
which doesn't really
make sense intuitively to me,
because at least classically,
it shouldn't be constant in tau.
PROFESSOR: OK.
That's the next
thing I wanted to say
is I've swept here-- I
just wanted to give you
the structure of the
operators and not
get distracted by
discussing time.
I've dropped the
time argument here.
But the fact is that as
long as we limit ourselves
to a single mode of the
electromagnetic field,
a single harmonic oscillator,
things are independent of tau.
In other words, g2 of
tau equals g2 of 0,
as long as we're dealing
with single mode light.
You can actually say--
and that sort of tells you
where the fluctuations
come-- if g2 of tau changes,
it comes because you
have several modes
of the electromagnetic field,
which, as a function of time,
constructively and
destructively interfere.
But if you have a single
mode, in a single mode--
and what is a single mode?
It's just a sine wave.
And nothing happens
as a function of time.
It's constant.
AUDIENCE: So both
modes go inside.
PROFESSOR: I'm squeezing a
textbook of quantum optics
into two classes.
And I want to give you the
ideas and the concepts.
What I've sort of mixed
up here deliberately
is I've given you the classic
definition of the intensity
correlation function, which is
the famous Hanbury Brown Twiss
experiment, and
used correlations
as a function of time.
Then I've motivated
how this should
be defined for quantum
states of light.
But when I transitioned to
quantum states of light,
I decided to deal with
only one mode of the light.
We should now sum
over-- I should
put double or triple
indices on all the alphas
for polarization,
for spatial modes,
for different frequencies,
and we sum over all of them.
But instead what I did is
I wanted to just show you
the simple case-- and I
think you will be thankful
for that in your
homework, that you only
have to deal with
the simple case--
that you only have to
look at a's and a daggers
in the operator algebra
for single mode,
for single harmonic oscillator.
But what we lose,
so to speak here,
is there is nothing
interesting going on in time.
I've already told you that,
for a single mode, all
of these quasi-probabilities,
they just rotate in a circle.
So the time evolution
of the system
you're describing right
now is completely boring.
It's really a rotation.
And if you would rotate
your head at omega,
nothing will happen.
And this is exactly
what you see here.
So you find everything you
want to for coherence time.
Coherence time is the time for
2 modes to get out of phase.
But if you have 1 mode,
there is no coherence time.
And when you find,
for classical light,
that the g2 function has a peak
which decays with the time,
it is the time for modes
to get out of phase.
But in a single mode
picture, this is absent.
Anyway, what is important now
for the discussion of quantum
character of light
is really, we find
that in a single mode picture.
So I want to show you
now-- or at least give you
the summary of
the results, which
can be very easily derived,
because the math is very
simple of those
operators, that we are now
with that definition.
We have g2 functions, which
are no longer following
the classic constraint that
g2 has to be larger than 1.
We find g2 functions
which are smaller than 1.
And this sort of
tells us now where
do we find the most
non-classical behavior,
namely when g2 of tau
is as small as possible.
OK.
In your homework, you
will show immediately
that the g2 function is
related to number fluctuations.
It's related to an average
and an n-squared average.
Let me just write that down.
It's independent of tau.
And the reason is we have
now limited ourselves
to just one mode of the
electromagnetic field.
Fano factor.
Just give me one--
OK So we are back
to-- We started
with intensity fluctuations.
But for a single mode of
the electromagnetic field,
we are back to photon numbers.
So what we are now expressing
with the g2 function
are, in other words, just
fluctuations of photon numbers.
I want to in a minute
draw you a table.
What are the fluctuations
in the photon number
for the states we have
encountered-- the number
state, the Fock state,
the coherent state,
and the thermal state?
And we want to characterize
those quantum states of light
by the g2 function.
And actually, I can drop to
time argument or set it to 0.
But then we first
make a reference
that g2 can now
be smaller than 1.
So g2 for a single mode light
is nothing else than a function.
When you know what is an
average and n squared average,
you know your g2 function.
There is another
quantity, which we often
use to characterize the
fluctuations in the photon
number.
And this is called
the Fano factor.
The Fano factor is-- wants
to compare the fluctuations.
n square average minus
n average squared,
these are the fluctuations.
The classical
fluctuation-- well,
I say classical, classical
in the simplest case--
are Poissonian fluctuations.
So maybe we want to
normalize the fluctuations
by Poissonian fluctuation.
So for Poissonian statistics,
what I just wrote down
would be 1.
And well, if you
now subtract 1, we
have the situation that
the final factor, which
is positive, is
super-Poissonian--
more fluctuation
than Poissonian--
and the negative final
factor is sub-Poissonian.
So with those
definitions, we can now
compare the different states
of light we have introduced.
We started out with black-body
radiation, thermal radiation.
We defined coherent states.
And the harmonic oscillator
description naturally
gave us harmonic
oscillator eigenstates,
the number of states,
or Fock states.
So there are three ways
to characterize it.
They are all useful.
One is we can look at n squared.
We can calculate
the Fano factor.
Or we can calculate g2 of 0.
For the coherent
state-- remember,
the coherent state
is as close as we
can come quantum
mechanically to the ideal
of a pure electromagnetic wave.
It has a Fano factor of 0.
This means it's Poissonian.
The g2 function
is simply 1, which
is the lowest classical limit.
So those two tell you that a
coherent state is sometimes
what you think-- what
comes out of a laser is
an ideal electromagnetic
wave, which
has no temporal fluctuations
in the intensity.
Therefore, g2 is 1.
And the photon number is
Poissonian distributed.
And that means that n
squared is an average times 1
plus an average.
We actually
discussed it earlier.
The thermal state
is quite different.
If you use-- kind
of pluck together
the results we have obtained,
it has a Fano factor of n-bar.
So this is super-Poissonian.
If the occupation
number n is large,
you have fluctuations
which are much,
much larger than
Poissonian fluctuation.
The g2 function is 2.
It's sometimes
called thermal light.
Chaotic light has
a g2 function of 2.
Laser light or coherent state
has a g2 function of one.
And n square average is
n-bar 1 plus 2 n-bar.
OK.
But now finally, maybe
the most interesting state
from the perspective of
non-classical light--
of quantum light-- is
the photon number state.
Well, for the photon number
state, the number of photons
is an eigenvalue.
Therefore, n squared average
is n average squared.
The Fano factor is minus 1.
Sub-Poissonian distribution.
And the g2 function, which
classically cannot go below 1,
is now n minus 1 over n.
It is smaller than 1.
And you see immediately that
the biggest violation for g2
is to go to minus 1 for the
case of a single photon state.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't it
be 0 for [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: The g2 function?
No, if you put in-- wait.
Yes.
Gosh.
I'll double-check.
I'm a little bit confused.
But I-- At least
it's consistent now.
I'm not sure if it's
right, but it's consistent.
By the way, if
there is a question,
I sometimes make a
question mark in my notes.
And when I post the
notes-- maybe not when
I post the notes
on the next day,
but a few days later-- the
question marks are eliminated.
Just as an example,
last class, there
was some relation
for which I didn't
remember how the
derivation was done.
When I post those notes
today, the derivation
is now in the notes.
I'm not announcing
it separately.
But whenever I have a
question mark in class
and I don't think it's
worth an extra announcement,
it is fixed in the
posted notes and you
find the information there.
OK.
So this is now drawing our
attention to the single photon.
And this is our next subsection.
This shouldn't come unexpected.
If you want to emphasize the
difference between quantum
light and classic light,
where does it come from?
Well, it comes from the
quantization of light.
It comes from the
photon character.
effect that light is not
a continuous stream of energy,
it comes quantized in photons.
So the granularity of light
due to the photon character
is, of course, most pronounced
for a single photon.
For instance, when we
define the g2 function
as a correlation of
detecting a photon
and detecting
another photon, well,
if you've only one photon,
you find one photon,
and for the next photon, there
is no photon to be detected.
So the probability of
detecting two photons is 0.
And that only happens when you
go down to similar photons.
So this is when
certain fluctuations
are most pronounced,
because the energy is
dependant on a singular photon.
Let me first address
one misconception.
You can say, Well, let's
just use a coherent state.
And we talk about
the attenuator--
the quantum attenuator
with all its operator
beauty-- probably not today
but it the next lecture.
But let me already sort
of prepare you for that.
When you have a coherent state,
when you have a laser beam,
you can put an attenuator.
And your laser beam gets
weaker and weaker and weaker.
But it stays a coherent state.
And I will prove that
to you very soon.
So you can now say that you
take your coherent state
and you attenuate it down that
there is only one photon left.
Is that a single photon state?
The answer is no.
It is an attenuated
coherent state.
Coherent states, as I've just
shown you, are very classical.
They've always
Poissonian distribution.
They've always a
g2 function of 1.
And attenuation is
not changing it.
Attenuation is preserving that.
So now I want to
show you explicitly
why an attenuated coherent
state may have an average photon
number of 1 but it shares
nothing else with a quantum
state of 1 photon of
n equals 1 Fock state.
So a coherent state with an
expectation value of 1 photon
is not a single photon.
And this can be, for
instance, expressed
by looking what is
actually the probability,
if you have such
a coherent state,
to find 1, 2, or 3 photons.
Well, the probability to find
0 photons-- no photon at all--
is actually 1/3.
So the probability to find 1
photon or to find 0 photons
is the same.
The probability to
find 2 photons is 0.18.
So here you have a probability
of finding a photon
and correlating it with
the next photon click.
And you have even,
on first sight,
a surprisingly large probability
to find 3 and 4 photons.
So in 2 percent of the cases,
you will find 4 photons.
Whereas in contrast, the Fock
state with quantum number n
equals 1 is an eigenstate
of the number operator
beta with eigenvalue n equals 1.
So that tells you, if you
want to get n equals 1,
if you want to get a
single photon state,
you cannot just use a strong
laser beam or a strong light
source and attenuate it.
You have to work with something
which genuinely creates only 1
photon without any ambiguity,
without any fluctuations,
without any possibility
of creating 2 photons.
And I would actually say
over the last 10 or 15 years,
the creation of
single photons has
been sort of a small
cottage industry,
because single photons are often
needed for protocols in quantum
computation-- for experiments
which really require accurate
quantum state
preparation of light--
and in particular,
non-classical light.
But of course, there are ways
how you can get single photons.
And this is, well, you
start with single atoms.
If you have a single atom
in the excited state,
it can emit only one photon.
So in other words,
you cannot-- Usually,
we don't have the tools to
prepare a single photon--
to take a single photon
out of many, many photons--
and store it separately.
But what we can control
is single atoms.
We can prepare single atoms.
And then we can make
sure that single atoms
create single photons.
It's a little bit a way that
we cannot control the bullets
which are fired.
But we can control the guns.
And we make sure that each gun
can emit exactly one bullet.
So that's a way
how we can create
non-classical states of light.
Yes.
So let's now look for
those single photons
at the quasi-probability
distribution.
So we obtain the
quasi-probability distribution
by taking the
single photon state
and projecting it
on a coherent state.
You remember-- it's higher
up in the notes-- what
the coherent state alpha
is in the Fock state basis,
in a number basis.
And so we're just
picking out n equals 1.
And this was nothing
else than alpha
squared times e to the
minus alpha squared.
So therefore, in these
diagrams with the real part
and imaginary part, if I
plot the quasi-probability
distribution, we get a ring.
The ring immediately tells us
that there is no phase defined.
All the phases are
equally probable.
And that also
means, if you don't
have a phase, the average value
of the electric field this 0.
Since the equation
of single photons
is essential for studying
non-classical light,
but also since it's a very
active frontier of our field--
actually, one of the
leaders in this field
is Professor Vladan
Vuletic here at MIT--
let me at least give
you a taste of how
to create single photons.
I already gave you
the major ingredient.
Namely, it's about-- it
involves single atoms.
But it's a little bit
more demanding like that.
So you want to take
1 atom home or 1 ion.
But the problem is if the
atom or ion emits a light,
it can emit the light
into all directions.
And therefore, you have a
single photon afterwards.
But you have many, many
different spacial modes.
And in any given mode, it
will not have a single photon.
So therefore, what you have
to add to the single atom
or single ion is-- you
have to put it in a cavity.
And then, in the limit of a
very, very high finesse cavity,
the probability will
be very, very high
that your photon is emitted
into the mode of the cavity
and it is not emitted
perpendicular into other modes.
But that itself is
not yet sufficient,
because you have
a single photon,
but you also want to know when
does the single photon arrive.
You want to do experiments.
You want single
photons on demand.
And so one option is that
you prepare your atoms
in the ground state.
You take a pi pulse, which,
with 100 percent probability,
excites the atom to
the excited state.
And then within an
actual lifetime,
or maybe even in
resonator-enhanced inverse
natural line widths, the
single photon is emitted.
So therefore, you
pump the system
and then you know within
the next few nanoseconds
your cavity mode will
have a single photon.
The problem here is
that you're dealing--
You have to prepare single
atoms, which is difficult.
You have to couple them
to a high finesse cavity.
There is technically
another approach,
where you use many atoms.
So you could say
that many atoms,
you no longer have a single gun.
So therefore, you can
get several photons.
But the singleness in photons
comes because the photons
are now heralded--
they are announced.
And the idea is the following.
If you start with the state 1,
and you have an excited state,
and you have a pump pulse.
Now, if you have many atoms, you
have a much higher efficiency
of pumping atoms comes
to the excited state,
because if you have n atoms,
it's n times more efficient.
But now you take the
following situation.
You wait until there
is a Raman transition--
until you detect the photon
for Raman transition,
where the excited state
decays to the state 2.
At this moment, you know I
have now 1 atom in state 2.
So in other words,
you're not starting
with single atoms, which is
sometimes more demanding.
How can you prepare the system?
It has other disadvantages
that n atoms have.
I'm not sure if I should
mention it, but with n atoms,
they have a super-radiant
factor n with n atoms.
You can get an n-times
enhancement of emission
into a single mode.
So there are real,
massive advantages
in working with many atoms.
But now you know that
one atom is in state 2
when you detect
the first photon.
And then you have the same
situation which we had above.
You can now take your
system-- let me just
redraw the level diagram.
Excited state, state 1, state 2.
You know now that you
have 1 single atom here.
And by using a laser
pulse, you can excite it
to the excited state.
And then you observe
the single photon 2.
So in other words,
the observation
off the first photon
tells you that your system
is prepared with
1 atom in state 2.
And then you can get
a single photon out
of it, which is the photon
for the inverse Raman
transition when you pump
the system back to state 1.
AUDIENCE: Doesn't
this rely on you
being able to reliably prepare
a single atom in another quantum
state?
Won't there always
be some uncertainty
as to how many atoms you
can prepare in one sitting?
PROFESSOR: There are
some uncertainties.
And what you're
saying is correct.
We don't have perfect
single photon sources.
And people characterize the
fidelity of the single photon
source.
For instance, if you detect the
single photon, you would say,
Now my system is ready to
emit a single photon triggered
by this pump pulse.
And if you can get
now a single photon
in 90 percent of the cases,
you publish a wonderful paper,
because you've set a new
record for the fidelity
of a single photon source.
So people are really
struggling with some
of those uncertainties.
But to involve, for
instance, three levels
is sort of an advantage,
because you're not
limited by the preparation of
a single atom, for instance.
You can have many atoms.
The atoms are always there.
And the moment one atom
is prepared in state 2,
this atom announces itself
with a single photon.
So it takes a lot of uncertainty
out that the system says,
with the first
photon, I'm ready now.
I can emit a single photon.
And then you get
your single photon.
Then you can gate
your whole experiment
to a time following the
detection of the first photon.
And for your gated
time afterwards, you
have a very, very
high probability
of finding this photon.
Or if you want, you can now
do experiments with 2 photons.
If you keep this laser on and
pump the atom immediately back,
you have actually a
single photon here,
followed by a
single photon here.
It's sort of click clack.
And now you can do
correlations between two
different single
photon states and such.
It's a very rich
frontier of our field.
You have another question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is this also within a cavity
now, like the single photon
[? reflection ?]
in the first test?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Actually, these photons--
the wavy lines--
are emitted spontaneously.
Spontaneous emission,
pretty much by definition,
goes into all possible
spatial modes.
And the only way to control the
spatial mode is with a cavity.
What I don't want
to go into details--
but those who have an
understanding of that--
is the following.
If you n atoms and you prepare
one atom here in state 2,
you do not know which of
your n atoms is prepared.
So you have n indistinguishable
possibilities.
And if you have n
indistinguishable probabilities
which atom you have prepared,
the emission of the photon
back is n times enhanced.
So therefore, you
have actually a system
which has an n times stronger
coupling to the cavity.
So having n atoms makes
it much, much easier
to construct a high
finesse cavity.
You get this super
radiance increase
of the strong coupling for free.
And this is why there are
many reasons why you do not
want to work with the
single ion or a single atom.
It's possible.
For very fundamental
experiments,
people have shown
that it can be done.
But technologically,
it's much easier and much
more robust to work
with many atoms.
But then you need
the many atoms have
to tell you when 1 atom
is prepared to emit now
a single photon.
If you're interested
in this subject,
talk to the students
in [INAUDIBLE] school.
They're really the
world experts in that.
OK.
Finally, we're not really
getting to squeeze light.
We start with squeezing
the light tomorrow.
The last thing in
this major section
is the famous Hanbury
Brown Twiss experiment.
This was a landmark
experiment done in the 1950s.
And it was the first
experiment which
really looked at g2 functions
correlations, which one could
say was the beginning
of quantum optics
and modern experiments
with light.
Probably until then, light was
just an electromagnetic wave
people regarded as boring.
But by measuring
now correlations,
people realize that it's an
interesting object to study.
I want to just go
over the basic scheme.
You will look at it
a little bit more
closely in your
homework assignment.
So the idea behind an Hanbury
Brown Twiss experiment
is that you have a
light source and you
want to characterize it.
So the light source emits light.
And now, this is important.
Whenever you want
to detect 2 photons,
you want to figure out
it's 1 photon followed
by another photon.
Technically, you cannot do
it with a photomultiplier,
because when a photomultiplier
clicks, it needs many,
many nanoseconds for the
photomultiplier to read out
the signal and recover to
recharge up its electrodes
and be ready to detect
the next photon.
So therefore, when you
want to find click click--
double clicks in the
stream of light--
you have to involve
a beam splitter
and involve two photodetectors.
Sure, you now need an
adequate description.
But in principle,
you can now find
2 photons which are only
a few picoseconds apart,
because the first photon is
observed by the first detector,
and the second
photon is detected
by the second detector.
Sure, you would say, What
happens if you're in the beam
splitter, both photons
go to detector one?
Well, that's tough luck.
You take 1 chance in
2 that the 2 photons
go to the 2 different detectors.
But the beam splitter has to
be part of your experiment,
has to become part
of your description.
And this is what you do
in homework number one.
So what we are asking here when
we measure the g2 function.
Let's assume that tau equals 0.
We are reading out a signal.
And what we are using is
a coincidence detector.
We are looking that in a
very small temporal window,
2 photons are detected
simultaneously.
Well, this is the
quantum version.
The classical version
is the g2 function
is the product of the
intensity at time t times
the product of the intensity
at time t plus tau.
So what you would do
here in this circuit,
you would take the signal
from this detector, the signal
from that, and multiply the two.
This is how you determine I
of t times I of t plus tau.
So whether you do it
in the classical domain
or whether you do it
in the quantum domain,
this is the way how
you experimentally
measure the second order
correlation function.
In the classic limit, you
don't have to worry about it.
The classical limit is always
a limit of high intensity.
So at any given time, you
have a ton of photons.
And then, at beam splitter,
half of the photons go left,
half of the photons go right.
You have an equal splitting.
You have exactly
half the intensity
in the left arm and the right
arm after the beam splitter.
So there is no problem at
all with the quantization,
because this is the
classical limit.
So classically you
can say-- actually,
I shouldn't say photon, I
should actually say intensity.
The intensity splits equally.
And if you do the measurement
with the coincidence detector,
you find the difference
between the g2 function,
which I discussed earlier.
That the g2 function is 1 for
coherent light or laser light,
and the g2 function is
2 for thermal light.
That's actually the only
way how you can distinguish
a light bulb from a laser beam.
If you put a light bulb into
a cavity or couple the light
from a light bulb into
a fiber, the light
becomes spatially a single mode.
If you put a very
narrow spectral filter
or Fabry-Perot cavity,
the light becomes
single mode in frequency domain.
So when you take a light bulb
and spatially and spectrally
filter it that it is single
mode, in terms of the mode,
it is single mode as
a single mode laser.
But it is the
correlation experimental
which shows you that you
started with a thermal source.
It has a g2 function of 2, and
you can never get rid of it,
whereas the laser beam
has a g2 function of 1.
OK.
So this is the
classical version.
In the quantum version,
especially when
we have a single
photon, the photon
can go to only one detector.
And that means, for this
extreme case of a single photon,
the g2 function is 0.
Anyway, you will look at
those situations in more
detail in you
homework assignment.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Sir, if you
know that different
for tau non-zero, then even
the single mode in the function
would have a final g2
[INAUDIBLE], because there
would be some
probability [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: We have to be
now a little bit careful.
If you have a single mode Fock
state, there's only 1 photon.
And once this photon is
detected, we have vacuum,
we have no photon left.
So what may be confusing
here is, on first sight,
is that the way how the
experiment is done and has been
historically done, it's
not done we Fock states.
It's done with the light
source in a continuous stream
of photons.
So Hanbury Brown
Twiss experiment,
he looked at in
light bulb, or he
looked at star light and such,
and determined the intensity
correlation.
He couldn't do the
experiment with lasers,
but now we would
with a laser beam.
And we find that g2 is 1.
But in those
situations, we actually
do not have the way-- we
have actually a beam, which
is a stream of photons.
And this requires a little
bit different description.
In other words, when I
have a coherent state,
a laser beam is
always replenishing
the coherent state.
The laser beam preserves
the electric field,
whereas, strictly speaking,
the way how I described it
for pedagogical reasons is
you have a cavity, which
is filled with a
coherent state alpha.
And then you start
analyzing that.
But in other words,
what we have focused
in the simple description
is that we have a quantum
state which is prepared--
it's a closed system.
And now we do our detection.
The experiment how
it is done is often
done as in an open system,
where you couple the system
to a light source,
which is always
replenishing your experiment.
So to be careful, especially
with a single photon.
I think, in essence,
the experiment
would be done with a
single photon light source.
But the single
photon light source
has a high repetition rate.
I showed you how to
generate single photons.
You have an heralded
single photon.
You know the single
photon comes now.
You do the experiment.
And then you repeat it again.
And then what you
have is you only
look at one single
photon bunch at a time.
And then you find indeed, that
during that temporal window,
you will never find
a second photon.
So this may happen
in a few nanoseconds.
Then you wait a microsecond,
and the next photon arrives.
Of course, if you would now
describe your light source,
what you is the g2 of tau,
and tau is a microsecond,
and the microsecond is the time
between the first single photon
burst and the next
single photon burst,
now you will find that
your g2 function is not 0.
But this is then related
to the repetition
rate of a single photon and not
to the single photon itself.
I think you've got the taste.
Your homework is
a really simple.
You just deal with
a closed system.
You look at a quantum
state at a time.
But if you map it onto
a beam experiment,
you have to think
about what does it
mean to have a replenishment
of the quantum state.
Any question?
I know I have to stop, but.
AUDIENCE: In the beam
splitter, the other port
of the beam splitter should
do some stuff, right?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Actually, this will keep us busy
for a while, that even if you
do not put in any light,
we put in the vacuum state.
And you will find that the
description of the beam
splitter in the quantum
state is incomplete,
unless you specify that your
beam splitter is coupling
in from a different
mode the vacuum state.
Yes, this will be
very important.
And we will cover it
in its full glory.
AUDIENCE: I just have
a quick question.
The way we can distinguish
from a thermal state
and a coherent state
is through the g2.
So from an experimental
perspective,
could we do most of
experiments if we just
had thermal sources that were
very single mode, so to speak?
PROFESSOR: Well, yes.
All the laser cooling, all the
[INAUDIBLE], all the absorption
imaging-- all that would
work if you had a single mode
thermal source.
Let's face it, we say we
use lasers for everything
we're doing.
But the only property
which distinguishes
a laser from the thermal
light source-- we're
not taking advantage of it.
Of course practically, if
you take a thermal source
and filter it down
to a single mode,
you will be left with
only a few photons.
You cannot create an intense
enough single mode light source
unless you use stimulated
emission into a single mode.
And that's a laser.
Colin.
AUDIENCE: The correlation
function for, for example,
an LED light-- that's not
really a thermal source.
It's not described by a
Maxwell-Boltzmann distribution.
And that would be closer
to something for a laser,
even though there is no cavity?
PROFESSOR: Well, LEDs in some
limit are quantum objects.
Actually, do you know what
the g2 function of LED is?
Does it become
laser-like, or does it
become even antibunched?
Because if it's a relaxation
mechanism-- So anyway,
what Colin says is
there are actually
more different light
sources that just the laser
and the thermal light source.
There are LEDs or semiconductor
devices, which provide photons
with interesting
statistical properties.
I've heard about it-- that
LED light sources have
some special
properties, but I don't
remember which was the one.
OK.
We have to stop.
I'll see you on Wednesday.